in my career I have seen several
technological advances that have changed
the way we communicate but none have
shaken the world as much as A.I has
recently
[Music]
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to this quick
thinks episode of think fast talk smart
the podcast
today I am excited to run an experiment
for the first time ever on this podcast
I will not be interviewing a person
instead I'll be interviewing an
algorithm chat GPT
chat GPT is an AI natural language
processing chat bot that allows users to
have human-like conversations the GPT
stands for generative pre-trained
Transformer
and it was launched by openai in
November of 2022. for today's experiment
in interview we will have typed in the
answers and we will be using a
programmed language to read out chat
gpt's responses
so let's get started with our experiment
welcome chat GPT thanks for being here
you're welcome I'm here to help so feel
free to ask me anything great let's get
started
for those of our listeners who aren't
familiar with exactly what you are can
you define your purpose and and give us
two examples
the purpose of chat GPT is to provide
informative and accurate responses to
questions in natural language two
examples answering factual questions for
example what is the capital of France
and generating creative text for example
write a story about a dragon wow now
that's impressive
where do you chat GTP get the
information you use to answer your
questions
chat GPT is a language model created by
openai that has been trained on vast
amounts of text Data from the internet
it uses this training to generate
responses to questions based on patterns
it has seen in the data essentially you
know what you know by pulling from all
the data on the internet so in some ways
you get your answers the way we do
through reflection and learning and
training to help us generate our
responses right yes that's correct chat
GPT has been trained on vast amounts of
text Data from the internet allowing it
to generate responses to questions based
on patterns and information found in
that data however it's important to note
that not all information on the Internet
is accurate or up to date so the
response is generated by chat GPT may
not always be 100 correct ah so now you
bring me directly to my next question
which is what safeguards does chat GPT
use to ensure its answers are
appropriate accurate and ethical it is
important to critically evaluate the
responses generated by chat GPT
and not rely on them as the sole source
of information I see hmm
now many teachers like myself hiring
managers and college admissions officers
worry that chat GPT might lead people to
cheat to be disingenuous what do you
think about that cheating undermines the
learning and evaluation process and is
not to be encouraged or condoned while
chat GPT can generate responses to
questions it is important for
individuals to understand the importance
of original work and to not use the
technology to substitute their own
efforts the ultimate responsibility for
ensuring academic integrity
and ethical Behavior lies with the
individuals using chat GPT and they
should use it in a manner that aligns
with their institutions policies and
guidelines so it's the user's
responsibility to use the tool
appropriately
now let me ask you for some advice and
guidance in a fun way
how would you suggest someone reduce
their speaking anxiety what I want you
to give your advice as a Dr Seuss rhyme
when it comes to speaking do not be so
blue just a few tips to help get you
through take a deep breath it'll calm
your mind and think of what you want to
say e kind remember it's normal to feel
a bit of fear but pushing through will
bring you cheer so be confident and
speak with pride your words will shine
they'll surely be a guide hey that's not
bad at all it's good advice and
certainly a fun way to hear it do we
still need to learn how to communicate
better now that you exist yes effective
communication skills are still essential
even with the existence of chat GPT
while chat GPT can provide information
and generate responses it cannot replace
the human interaction and emotional
intelligence that comes with
face-to-face communication furthermore
not all communication can be done
through technology and the ability to
communicate effectively in person
remains important in many settings such
as business meetings personal
relationships and public speaking
additionally develop helping strong
communication skills can enhance one's
confidence and ability to express
themselves effectively well that's good
to know
before we end I'd like to ask you the
same three questions I ask everyone who
joins me
question one if you were to capture the
best communication advice you ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would it
be listen speak authentically show
empathy wow your response is very
similar to what we've heard from many of
our guests you have to listen to really
know what's needed in the moment you
want to speak your truth be authentic to
yourself and you absolutely want to
demonstrate empathy and concern and
focus for your audience
let me ask question number two who is a
communicator that you admire and why
one Communicator I admire is Martin
Luther King Jr his speeches were
powerful impactful and delivered with
passionate conviction he effectively
communicated his message of equality and
justice for all inspiring social change
through his words his use of metaphors
repetition and vivid imagery made his
speeches memorable and enduring he
remains a powerful example of the impact
that effective communication can have
well absolutely all of us are familiar
with his I Have a Dream speech I
actually find his Nobel Prize acceptance
speech to be on par if not even better
than the I Have a Dream speech thanks
for sharing question three what are the
first three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe
active listening Clarity and empathy
well your response is no surprise It
lines up with the slide title that you
shared before I find it fascinating that
an AI algorithm is talking about
listening and empathy I have to spend
some time thinking about that
well chat GPT thank you for sharing your
thoughts I find this really intriguing
and interesting and I can truly see the
value of a tool like yourself in helping
us to prepare to take on and create
different options for our communication
clearly if I were a non-native speaker
it could be very helpful to get ideas
about how to formulate these thoughts
and use the proper vocabulary
but I have to admit I have some concerns
I'm not sure about the emotion the
connection
the validity of some of the information
like many of us I am intrigued by but
also concerned about what you bring to
our world of communication
thank you for being here and for making
us think
you're welcome I'm here to help okay one
last favor chat GPT can you write our
outro yes I can
foreign that's it for today's episode of
think fast talk smart we hope you found
it informative and thought-provoking if
you enjoyed the show please share it
with your friends and colleagues we'd
also love it if you subscribe to the
podcast and followed us on LinkedIn and
Instagram and don't forget to sign up
for our email newsletter to stay up to
date on all things related to
communication and public speaking thanks
for listening and until next time keep
thinking fast and talking smart